Speaker 1: Let's go to Andrew from
California. Andrew from California,
welcome. What's on your mind?
Speaker 2: Hi. First time caller,
longtime listener.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 2: I'm kind of nervous,
but I'll power through it.
Speaker 1: Yeah, you're doing great so far.
Speaker 2: I just wanted to discuss with
you about the when dealing with irrational like
Trump Trump supporters. Yeah, well, what is the
calculus? Because I've seen a lot of progressive
hosts handle it both ways, where they're like very
patient and charitable in a sense, versus like
just steamrolling them and then just hanging up
on them and not letting them talk. Like, for
example, with you, you had that guy who you
guys were getting into like the semantics of
like Trump not being allowed with the nuclear
codes. And I feel like you took like a charitable
approach, which I agree I agreed with you, but I
felt like you could have been more charitable. But
I don't know. I'm just a schmuck. I don't know.
Speaker 1: So listen, it depends what you want to
achieve, right? I mean, my point with that guy,
that was Bobby Polo. The reason I gave that guy
so much time and so much leeway was he was one
of those guys who showed up in our super chats
during a live stream and said, I want to debate
you and you won't debate me and you won't give me
time and blah, blah, blah, blah, blah. And so the
point I was trying to make was, I'll gladly give
you time and I'll allow you every opportunity to
make your point. And the guy had 10 minutes and
he quite literally wasn't able to make a single
point. And the point of that was less about
telling him he was wrong about every particular
issue. He didn't even bring up an issue. That was
the funny thing. The guy was desperate to debate
and couldn't actually even hold a conversation. So
that was more about like these people who are big,
tough guys on the Internet who want a debate, then
you give them a chance. They they make no sense.
They might as well be speaking a foreign language
in other situations on somebody who comes at me
with a particular issue that they're wrong about,
then it would be less about being as charitable as
possible and more about showing them that they're
actually wrong on the issue. Does that make sense,
Andrew? Like, it depends on the situation.
Speaker 2: Yeah, I guess it's. I don't know.
I guess sometimes I. I prefer the more charitable
approach. I just feel like maybe then there'd be
more of a chance of. Connection. But
maybe that's just wishful thinking.
Speaker 1: No, I think on balance, you're
right. It just with that particular guy you're
thinking of, it went nowhere because there was no
substance to it. You know, we could he wouldn't
even understand what my position was. And yet he
still tried to tell me I'm wrong. But it's like,
dude, you don't even understand what
I'm saying. How can we go forward here?
Speaker 2: I felt like with the nuclear weapons
issue, which I think was like the one that kind of
ballooned. Yeah, I felt like it could have been a
little bit more like, okay, when you make a black
and white statement or I don't think Trump should
be around nuclear weapons, which is ridiculous.
The president must, you know, have, you know,
access to that. I just think that it would be very
irresponsible. I didn't feel like you said it in a
way where he was going to be able to receive that
and digest it and maybe understand that. I mean.
Speaker 1: Well, I think you're right. I don't
think he was going to be able to understand what
I was saying. But the extent to which I just have
to keep restating it, I think, you know, he
had a bunch of time and he wasn't getting it,
so it was just time to move on, you know?
Speaker 2: Okay. All right. One last comment.
Bring back Jimmy from Philly.
Speaker 1: I haven't heard from
him for years. Andrew, It's crazy.
Speaker 2: I just miss his voice.
Speaker 1: Fair enough. Maybe we can find that
impersonator. All right, Andrew. Thanks so much
for the call. Thank you. All right. There goes
Andrew with a very, very powerful declaration